لم يكتفي وزير الماليه الاسرائيلي زعيم
حزب الصهيونيه الدينيه اليمينيه المتطرف
بالتلقينش بوصف الشعب الفلسطيني بانه مجرد
وهم لم يتجاوز عمره 100 عام بل اختار
الوزير الاسرائيلي ان يقول هذا الكلام فوق
منصه تحمل خريطه تظهر اسرائيل بحدود موسعه
تشمل كامل الاردن والاراضي الفلسطينيه
المحتله
موقف وتصريحات سرعان ما اثارت موجه كبيره
من ردود الفعل اذ زرعت الخارجيه الاردنيه
الاستدعاء السفير الاسرائيلي في عمان
واصفه سلوك سموتريتش بالتصرف التحريضي
الارعن وبالخرق للاعراف الدوليه ومعاهده
السلام الاردنيه الاسرائيليه كما ذكر
الناطق الرسمي باسم الوزاره انه قد تم
ابلاغ السفير الاسرائيلي رساله احتجاج
شديده اللهجه لنقلها على الفور الى حكومته
مؤكدا ادانه الاردن ايضا للتصريحات
العنصريه التحريضيه المتطرفه ازاء الشعب
الفلسطيني الشقيق وحقه في الوجود وحقوقه
التاريخيه في دوله المستقله
الخارجيه الاسرائيليه سارعت بدورها للتبرئ
من خطوه الوزير الاسرائيلي بالتاكيد على
التزام اسرائيل باتفاق السلام مع الاردن
واعترافها بسلامه جميع اراضي المملكه
الاردنيه بحسب تعبير البيان على الجانب
الفلسطيني ادان رئيس الوزراء محمد شتيه
تصريحات سموت ريتش معتبرا اياها دليلا
قاطعا على الفكر العنصري المتطرف الذي
يحكم اطراف الحكومه الاسرائيليه الحاليه
ان هذه التصريحات التحريضيه منسجمه مع
المقولات الصهيونيه الاولى ارض بلا شعب
لشعب بلا ارض وان الاراضي الفلسطينيه
متنازع عليها وانها ارض الميعاد وهكذا من
ادعاءات وهي وهميه
من جهتها قالت حركه حماس ان حديث سموتريتش
يكشف العقيده السياسيه للكيان الاسرائيلي
وقال رئيس المكتب السياسي للحركه اسماعيل
هنيه ان هذه التصريحات تستوجب اداره حوار
استراتيجي مع الاردن
لمواجهه هذه التوجهات الخطيره في حين وصف
مفوض السياسات الخارجيه في الاتحاد
الاوروبي جوزيف بوريل تصريحات الوزير
الاسرائيلي بانها غير مقبوله ومرفوضه
تماما
هذه التعليقات مرفوضه من الوزير انه خطا
انه عدم احترام انه امر خطير من غير
المجدي قول هذا النوع من الاشياء في موقف
متوتر بالفعل سنواصل التزامنا الطويل
الامد بحل الدولتين مع اقامه دوله
فلسطينيه مستقله ذات السياده تعيش جنبا
الى جنب مع اسرائيل في سلام وامن
وكان اسمه
فبراير الماضي الى محو قريه حوار
الفلسطينيه في الضفه الغربيه المحتله
بعدها هجمات غير مسبوقه شنها مستوطنون على
البلده اسفرت عن استشهاد فلسطيني واصابه
عشرات اخرين واحراق وتدمير عشرات المنازل
والسيارات